véritable pionnier de la préhistoire
gabriel de mortiers dont on a célébré le
bicentenaire de la naissance en 2021 a
été un grand rire organisateurs du musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye l'iao vrai pendant près de vingt
ans il avait à gérer les collections du
musée qui ne cessé de s'enrichir
et puis il avait assuré l'intérim du
directeur donc c'est pour nous le moyen
d'approcher la vie au quotidien de notre
musée au 19e siècle alors que ce musée
vient d'être créée par napoléon iii en
1862 ancien maire de saint germain en
laye il n'avait pourtant pas fait
l'unanimité lors de son mandat en 1882
parmi ces mesures qui ont défrayé la
chronique
on a cette mesure d'abattre les croix
des cimetières de saint germain c'est un
anticlérical viscérale t7
anticléricalisme va vraiment dominé à la
fois sa vie politique mais également sa
vie au musée et sa vie scientifique
puisque il n'aura de cesse de démontrer
que l'homme a existé bien avant les
écrits bibliques vitrine ancien objets
paléolithique gravure ou encore
inventaire et registre des échanges de
l'administration du musée l'exposition
retrace le travail de ce géologue de
formation
il va également faire dessiner et gravés
sur des planches qui vont constituer un
album le premier album d'objets
préhistoriques et protohistoriques le
premier album attaché au premier
dictionnaire d'archéologie de la gaule
époque celtique à la première carte
archéologique
de la france ces gravures sont là pour
porter justement la classification
proposée par gabriel de mortier sur les
objets archéologiques
illustrant vraiment la préhistoire
quatre expositions temporaires de ce
type seront organisées chaque année la
prochaine portera sur le masque de
montherlant en 2022